but there is a difference between just
being mean to someone and being mean to
someone on the base of their gender or
their race there's a difference between
like how do you know the difference
because they quite literally explicitly
stated out saying you can't do this
because you're black you can't do this
because you're a woman you can't do this
because of that factor yeah good
question do you think you're entitled
what do you mean I think what is it she
has a problem with
that was given for watching how to do it
yeah the real question is the apostle
possibly didn't want her to
how to actually couldn't do it well what
is it
okay because you're a woman baby okay
[Music]
to carry across some beings
because you're a woman